Hola Qué tal Buenas tardes Bueno me tuve
que alejar un poco porque había tanta
gente que no nos podíamos conectar Así
que tal vez no se termina de captar el
ambiente pero también era súper intenso
donde estaba viéndolo aquí cerca unos
200 metros en una plaza de la ciudad de
Buenos Aires con un montón de gente que
se vea reunido frente a pantallas
gigantes mucha atención en la espera
mucha atención hasta que llegó ese
primer gol de Lionel Messi una especie
de
bálsamo para Argentina que llegaba muy
muy preocupada a este partido justo Un
día después de que se cumplieran los dos
años del fallecimiento de Diego Armando
Maradona tal vez una especie de homenaje
que Messi haya hecho este primer gol que
era clave para el futuro de la
clasificación de Argentina en este
mundial
natalio y ahora mismo que es lo que hace
la gente Cuál es el ambiente van a
continuar viendo otros partidos van a
seguir ahí en las calles
mi sensación fue que apenas terminó el
partido hubo como una especie respiramos
hondo nos relajamos y seguimos con
nuestro día había alguna gente que me
pareció que iba a irse a seguir de
fiesta había algunos móviles policiales
tocando Las Sirenas celebrando pero en
general una sensación más bien de alivio
había muchas familias también que
estaban como yendo a disfrutar del resto
desusado insisto yo creo que más allá de
la excitación inicial de los goles y del
triunfo que se celebró con mucha
intensidad hay alivio alivio porque
significa que Argentina sigue vivo para
este mundial